so in the realm of Marvel Comics we have
eternity the embodiment of the entire
earth-616 continuity we have Galactus
who goes around it consumes planets who
has powers so incredible now he's been a
fan favorite since his initial inception
and the Fantastic Four trilogy but
there's one man one earthbound character
who stands alone and we're going to talk
about him my peeps my comic and comic
gets today we're going to be doing a
video about the one and only Owen Reese
today we're going to be talking about
molecule man
so given everything that's going on in
the Marvel Universe right now the
impending end of all the realities and
Doctor Doom being revealed to be a
boo-boo Malala oh my god I'm ruined
molecule man is more important now that
he's ever been before
now we don't exactly know why we just
know that he is and so I figured right
now would be the best time to do a video
about the molecule man because what we
can do going forward is we can look at
his character knowing his past and we
can really understand the rule that he's
going to be playing with in the Secret
Wars event with him the lead-up to the
end of all these alternate realities and
the Marvel continuity so molecule man
first appeared in Fantastic Four volume
1 issue number 20 and he was created by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby now I've not
been able to find why it was they had
created him but I would go as far as to
say because he was made during this
early the early days of the Silver Age
in Marvel Comics he was most likely
simply just made as part of this mad
dash to create as many super villains
and superheroes as possible and then
just kind of throw them at the wall to
see which ones stick and so what happens
in Fantastic Four issue number 20 is
that Owen Reese is revealed to us to be
a man who basically has a very low image
of himself he had been raised in such a
way where he was really more of a mama's
boy than anything else and so as a
result when his mother had passed away
he had really began to garner the sort
of negative self-image about himself now
this was compounded by the fact that he
worked as a lowly lab technician within
the within the company of Acme Atomics
corporation and so as a result he's
basically working long hours he has very
little pay and he's really kind of
you're archetypical person who feels
like they're working a thankless job and
so what happens is that while he's
working on a particle accelerator I
guess he accidentally activates a
particle accelerator and the result is
that he ends up by developing his
abilities now the way in which he
develops his abilities was something
that we had covered during our
discussion about the Beyonder but for
those of you guys who didn't get a
chance to see it of course I'll have a
link in the description but the way that
this happens is that there were pockets
of energy that were placed around the
negative zone and whenever a portal is
open to one of these pockets of energy
the energy comes out and then a
containment unit is supposed to be I
guess created for the purpose of housing
this energy and this containment you
would go on to be referred to as a
cosmic cube but the problem was that
when Owen Reese had activated this
particle generator that there was no
containment unit there was nowhere for
this power to go and so as a result half
of the power went into Owen Reese gating
him by giving him his abilities and the
other half of the power kind of festered
and then manifested into the Beyonder
later on and so what we found over the
course of this this issue of the
Fantastic Four is that once on Reese
develops his powers this sort of
self-doubt that he has begins to really
become more of a mental block at the
same time he also develops this wand of
sorts and as far as he's concerned the
power that he possesses is within the
wand itself and the reason why is
because he cannot fathom that he would
have that kind of power that he would
have the ability to manipulate molecules
now the way that his power is initially
presented to us is actually revealed
when Reed Richards begins to analyze
molecule man then the reason why this
happens is because who ought to The
Watcher who had seen molecule man
developing his powers had informed Reed
Richards of what had gone on in the fact
that molecule man could basically live
to become an extremely dangerous person
who would not only go on to possibly
destroy the planet Earth but could also
lay ruin to the universe as a whole and
so when Reed Richards analyzes the
powers of the molecule man what he
realizes is that Owen Reese is only
capable of manipulating inorganic
particles meaning that he's only able to
manipulate the particles of things that
cannot become life that is to say he
cannot manipulate the particles of grass
or trees or the dirt or space itself he
can only manipulate the particles of
inanimate objects of desks and tree or
I'm sorry of desks and I guess maybe
cups and different things like that
nothing that has any real kind of of
life to it and so as a result what what
happens here is a fantastic Ford
developed this plan to basically send
molecule man away what happens here is
Alicia masters who is the girlfriend of
Ben Grimm the thing lures Owen Reese to
her apartment under the guise that she
will be able to I guess he'll be able to
meet with the Fantastic Four whom he's
basically made a kind of challenge to in
this sense that he's basically isolated
the city of New York and stated that
unless they bring themselves out the
city is going to stay the way it is
forever and so when the Fantastic Four
arrived to meet with Owen Reese what
happens here is that they basically make
themselves out to be
choose and so when I when Reese tries to
manipulate these statues he finds that
he can't do it again tapping into his
inability to manipulate organic
particles and so what Reed Richards does
is he takes this opportunity to send
molecule man to a different dimension
now this other dimension that molecule
man gets sent to is actually covered to
us later on and marvel kollek's again we
really wouldn't see molecule man for
quite some time but what model does here
is they tell us that while Owen Reese is
confined to this dimension he
effectively creates this sort of
offspring of source he creates this kind
of humanoid being and so what he does is
he basically sort of throws his
consciousness into this kind of end of
this wand that he possesses then as a
result this humanoid being is able to
transition this dimensional barrier and
travel back to the earth-616 continuity
and this is how this how molecule man
will exist for quite some time
molecule man will exist within the
confines of this wand think of it very
similar to through the Lord of the Rings
and so on that if a person takes
possession of this wand
they'll effectively be a controller I
guess will be able to be subjected so
didn't subject him by a molecule man and
molecule man will be able to exist
through them now what Marvel was
basically doing here was trying to find
a way to keep molecule man relevant but
remove his ability to manipulate
molecular matter the reason being
because the question became how many
stories could you really have with a man
who could manipulate molecules before
you got to the point whereby you had to
say his power has to go somewhere and so
DC eventually hit this roadblock I'm
sorry marvel II hit this roadblock in
the 1980s and when they ran into the
1980s we saw that Jim shooter had
written the secret Wars now with a
secret war event of course as we know
this was the Beyonder gaining sentience
as was the Beyonder taking all these
superheroes and supervillains confined
them to battle world and so on but as
the entire secret Wars event began to
come to a close what we found was that
when Doctor Doom had taken possession of
the powers of the Beyonder he had
realized what it was at Owen Reese was
capable of and so what happens here is
he basically takes Owen Reese aside and
he says that these powers that Owen
Reese has transitioned virtually
anything and anyone that is currently on
world with the exception of dr. doom
himself and so what he tells Owen Reese
is that he can basically manipulate the
entire fabric of reality if he wanted to
there's nothing that he can't do and so
this is basically Owen Reese moving away
from this negative aspect moving away
from this self doubt that he has about
himself and stepping into the role of
becoming a superhero and so this would
continue on into into the secret Wars
part 2 when the Beyonder travels to the
planet Earth when he begins to undertake
this role of trying to learn about
humanity and this is really when a lot
of people look at molecule man and say
this is when he stepped away from the
realm of being your run-of-the-mill
supervillain who had powers actually
becoming a more defined character but
what happens here initially is that the
Beyonder arrives to meet with molecule
man realizing the molecule man is really
the only other person that has the same
kind of power he does and so what
happens is molecule man basically tells
him if he wants to learn about humanity
he should spend time among humanity and
so again while things continue with the
Beyonder and the Beyonder continues to
get progressively more dangerous which
again was something we had covered
during our Beyonder video the attempt is
made on behalf of several superheroes
for molecule man to speak with the
beyond or to at the very least try to
intervene on the beyond or I guess on
the superheroes have against the
Beyonder but Owen Reese who is basically
isolated himself to a life of peace
doesn't want to have anything to do with
this he doesn't want to manipulate his
powers or use his powers in any way they
could really draw a whole lot of
attention to him but all this really
comes to a head when eventually the
Beyonder reaches such a scale of power
and begins to implement its power in
such a way to where our ultimate
conflict forms between molecule man and
the Beyonder whereby they fight over the
course of several dimensions they
actually have this big multi-dimensional
fight then this was Marvel basically
giving us the depth nature the in-depth
nature of how far molecule man's powers
go
if molecule man is able to manipulate
organic matter then he can manipulate
organic matter regardless of where that
matters at meaning that he can basically
transition dimensions he has power that
is for as far as we can tell on par with
the power of the Living Tribunal and so
this is what people are referring to
whenever you hear a discussion about
molecule man and they refer to him
as pre retcon molecule man this is the
height of his abilities now we would
find that molecule man would actually be
Rhett conned by Marvel when we got into
the 1990s when we got into the follow up
with the Beyonder and the events after
Secret Wars part two and what we found
here was that molecule man and the
Beyonder had basically converged into a
single being it was more of the powers
that had initially formed both of them
coming together to form a form or
cohesive unit and so as a result what we
found was that the Beyonder and and
molecule man who basically formed their
own kind of cosmic cube and then gone on
to form their own reality
now molecule man would eventually strip
his consciousness away from this a
reality per se from its own universe and
eventually return himself to the Marvel
landscape but from this point going
forward the Marvel molecule man really
doesn't play any prominent roles in
Marvel Comics he actually actually
becomes sort of this background
character for quite some time it's
actually not until the current events of
Marvel Comics it's to say what's going
on right now that molecule man has
become significant now with the current
events um what's taking place with time
runs out the lead-up to Secret Wars what
we know is that dr. doom is has been
revealed to us through a Bendre Booma
law but that he's basically attempting
to save the universe and what he's done
is he's enlisted molecule man to help
him do this now we don't know exactly
how it is that they're going to try to
save the universe we don't know how it
is they're going to even try to save the
multiverse as a whole all we know is
that at this moment right now molecule
man is somehow working in conjunction
with Doctor Doom to find some way to
preserve the multiverse as it exists in
the Marvel continuity with that being
said my peeps my marvel of Marvelettes
we're going to bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly
you